so if I can try to summarize
what a nuclear fusion reactor is
supposed to do
so you have what a couple of elements
what are usually the elements usually
deuterium and tritium which are the
heavy forms of hydrogen hydrogen you
have those and you start heating it
and then as you start heating it I
forgot the temperature you said about
100 million no first first it becomes oh
first it becomes plastic so it's a gas
and then it turns into a plasma at about
10 000 degrees and then so you have a
bunch of electrons and ions flying
around and then you keep heating the
thing
and uh I guess as you heat the thing the
ions hit each other rarer and rarer Yes
except oh man that's not fun so you have
to keep heating it
um such that uh you have to keep hitting
into the probability of them colliding
becomes reasonably high and so also on
top of that I'm sorry to interrupt you
have to prevent them from hitting the
walls of the reactor that's exactly
somehow so you asked about the the
definitions of the requirements for
Fusion so the most famous one or some
sense the most intuitive one is the
temperature and the reason for that is
that you you can make many many kinds of
plasmas that have zero Fusion going on
in them and the reason for this is that
the average so okay you can make a
plasma at around ten thousand in fact if
you come by the way you're welcome to
come to our laboratory at the psfc I can
show you a demonstration of a plasma
that you can see with your eyes instead
of about 10 000 degrees and you you can
put your hand up beside it and all this
and it's like and nothing there's zero
Fusion going on
so you have uh so what was the
temperature of the plasma about ten
thousand you can stick your hand in well
you can't stick your hand into it but
there's a glass tube you can basically
see this yeah yeah and you can put your
hand on the glass tube because it's
what's the color is it purple it's yeah
it's purple yeah
it is it is kind of beautiful um yeah
plasmas are actually quite uh
astonishing sometimes in their beauty
actually one of the most amazing forms
of plasma is Lightning by the way which
is is instantaneous form of plasma that
exists on Earth but immediately goes
away because everything else around it
it's at room temperature
yeah so there's different requirements
in this so making a plasma takes
about this but at 10 000 degrees even at
a million degrees there's almost no
probability of the fusion reactions
occurring and this is because while the
the charged particles can hit into each
other if you go back to the very
beginning of this remember I said oh
these charged particles have to get to
within distances which are like this
size of a nucleus because of the strong
nuclear force well
unfortunately as the particles get
closer this the repulsion that comes
from the charge the coulomb force
increases like the inverse distance
squared I don't know so as they get
closer they're pushing harder and harder
apart
so then then it gets a little bit more
exotic which you maybe you'll like
though that it turns out that you people
understood this and um at the beginning
of the uh of of the age of after
Rutherford discovered the nucleus it's
like oh yeah I was like how are we going
to how is this going to work right
because how do you get anything within
these distances inquire extraordinary
energy and it does and in fact when you
look at those energies they're very very
high
um but it turns out quantum physics
comes to the rescue because the
particles aren't aren't actually just
particles they're also waves this is the
point of quantum right the you can treat
them both as waves and as as particles
and it turns out if you get if they get
in close enough proximity to each other
then the particle pops through basically
this energy barrier through an effect
called Quantum tunneling which is really
just the transposition of the fact that
it's a wave so that it has a finite
probability of this it's it's this by
the way you talk about like do you have
a hard time like conceptualizing this
these are this is one of them yeah this
is like throwing a ping-pong ball like
at a a piece of paper and then every
like you know 100 of them just like
magically show up on the other side of
the paper without seemingly breaking the
paper I mean to use a physical analogy
yeah that's phenomena is important as uh
critical for the function of nuclear
fusion yeah all kinds of fusions so this
this is the reason why Stars can work as
well too like the stars would have to be
much much hotter actually to be able to
in fact it's not clear that they would
actually ignite in fact uh with without
this effect anyway so we get to that so
this is why there's another requirement
it's it's not so you must make a plasma
but you all also must get it very hot in
order for the reactions to have a
significant probability to actually fuse
and it actually falls effectively almost
to zero for lower temperatures as well
too so there's some nice equation yes
that gets you to 50 million degrees
or like uh yeah the or that you said
practically speaking 100 million so it's
a really simple equation it's the ideal
gas law basically almost so it's the in
the end you've got a certain number of
particle of these Fusion particles in
the plasma state they're in the plasma
State there's a certain number of
particles and if the confinement is
perfect if you put in a certain content
of energy then basically eventually they
just they come up in a temperature and
they become they they go up they go up
to high temperature this turns out to be
by the way extraordinarily small amounts
of energy
and you go what it's like I'm getting
something to like 100 million degrees
that's gonna take the biggest flame
burner that I've ever seen no
and the reason for this is it goes back
to the energy content of of this so yeah
you have to there's you have to get it
to high average energy but there's very
very few particles this is low density
low density in the reactor is this so
you the way that you do this is
primarily again this is not exactly true
in all kinds of fusion but in the in the
primary one that we work on a magnetic
Fusion this is all happening in a hard
vacuum so it's like it's happening in
outer space so basically you've gotten
rid of all the other particles except
for these specialized one at a time
uh no actually it's even easier than
that you you connect a gas valve and you
basically leak gas into it in a
controlled fashion yeah yeah well this
is beautiful the gas cylinder how do you
get it from hitting the walls yeah so
now you've touched on the other
necessary requirements so it turns out
it's not just temperature that's
required you must also confine it
so what does this mean confine it and
there's two types of confinement as you
mentioned you mentioned the magnetic one
magnetic one and there's another one
called inertial as well too but the
general principle actually has nothing
to do with in particular with what you
what with the technology is that you use
to confine it it's because
this goes back to the fact that the
requirement in this is high temperature
and thermal content so it's like
Building A Fire Man and what this means
is that if you when you release the
energy into this or or apply heat to
this if it just instantly leaks out it
can never get hot right so you're
familiar with this it's like you've got
something that you're you're trying to
apply heat to but you're just throwing
the heat away very quickly this is why
we insulate homes by the way and things
like those right it's like you don't
want the heat that's coming into this
room to just immediately leave because
you'll just start consuming infinite
amounts of heat to try to keep it hot so
in the end this is one of the
requirements and it actually has a name
we call the energy confinement time so
this means if you release a certain
amount of energy into this fuel
um kind of how long you sit there and
you look at your watch how long does it
take for this energy to like leave the
system so you could imagine in this room
that you know these heaters are putting
energy into the air in this room and you
waited for a day but all the Heat have
gone to outside if I open up the windows
oh there that's energy confinement time
okay so it's the same concept as that so
this is an important one so all Fusion
must have confinement there's another
more esoteric reason for this which is
that people often confuse temperature
and energy
so what I mean by that so this is
literally a temperature which means that
it is a system in which all the
particles every particle has high
kinetic energy and is actually in a
fully relaxed State namely that entropy
has been maximized and it gets a little
bit more technical but this means that
basically it is it is a thermal system
so it's like the air in this room it's
like the water it's the water in this
these all have temperatures which means
that there's a distribution of those
energies because the particles have
collided so much that it's there so we
this is distinguished from having high
energy particles like what we have in
like particle accelerators like CERN and
so forth those are high kinetic energy
but it's not a temperature so it
actually doesn't count as confinement so
we go through all those you have
temperature
um and then the other requirement not
too surprising is actually that there
has to be enough density of the fuel
enough but enough but not too much yes
and so in the end
um the way that it there's a fancy name
for it it's called The Lawson Criterion
because it was it was it was formulated
by scientists in the United Kingdom
about 1956 or 1957 and this was
essentially the realization of oh this
is what it's going to take regardless of
the confinement method these are this is
the basic what it is actually Power
Balance this just says oh there's a
certain amount of heat coming in which
is coming from the fusion reaction
itself because the fusion reaction heats
the fuel
um versus how fast you would lose it and
it basically summarizes summarized by
those three parameters which is fairly
simple so temperature and then the
reason we say 100 million degrees is
because almost always in in for for this
kind of fusion deuterium trading
infusion the minimum in the density and
the confinement time product is at about
100 million so you almost always design
your device around that minimum minimum
and then you try to get it contained
well enough and you try to get enough
density so you know so that temperature
thing sounds crazy right that's what
we've actually achieved in the
laboratory like our experiment here at
MIT when it ran it's Optimum
configuration it was at 100 million
degrees
but it wasn't actually the the product
of the density in the confinement time
wasn't sufficient that we were at a
place that we were getting high net
energy gain but it was making Fusion
reactions so this is the sequence that
you go through make a plasma then you
get it hot enough and when you get it
hot enough the fusion reactions start
happening so rapidly that it's
overcoming the the rate that which is
leaking heat to the outside world and at
some point it just becomes like a star
like a sun and our own our own son and a
star doesn't have anything plugged into
it it's just keeping itself hot through
its own Fusion reactions in the end
that's really close to what a fusion
power plant would look like what does it
visually look like does it does it look
like like you said like purple plasma
you know yeah actually it's it's
invisible to the eye because it's so hot
that it's basically emitting light in
frequencies that we can't detect
it's literal it's invisible
in fact light goes through it visible
light goes through it's so easy that if
you were to look at it what you would
see
in in our own particular configuration
what we make is in the end is a donut
shaped um it's a vacuum vessel to keep
the air out of it and when you in when
you turn on the plasma it gets so hot
that most of it just disappears in the
visible spectrum you can't see anything
and there's very very cold plasma which
is between 10 and 100 000 degrees which
is out in the very periphery of it which
is kind of so the very cold plasma is
allowed to interact with the and kind of
has to interact with something
eventually at the boundary of the vacuum
vessel and this kind of makes a little
halo around it and it glows this
beautiful purple light basically and
these are that's the um that's the
that's what we can sense in the human
Spectrum yeah I I remember reading on uh
subreddit called shower thoughts
uh which people should check out it's
just fascinating philosophical ideas
that strike you while you're in the
shower and one of them was it's lucky
that a fire when it burns communicates
that it's hot using visible light
otherwise humans would be screwed
um I don't know if there's a deep
profound truth to that but nevertheless
I did find it on shower thought
subreddit actually I do have there this
goes off in a bit of you're right this
is actually it's interesting because you
know as a scientist you also think about
evolutionary functions and how we got
like why do we have the senses that we
do yes interesting question like why can
bees see an UltraViolet and we can't
then you go well it's natural selection
for some reason this wasn't really
particularly important to us right why
can't we see in the infrared and other
things can it's like
because the people that could it's a
fascinating question right obviously
there's some there's some advantage that
you have there that isn't there and even
color distinguishing right of something
safe to ease not say whatever it would
be uh I actually go back to this because
it's something like that I tell all of
my my students when I'm teaching
um ionizing radiation and radiological
safety whatever you say there's a
cultural concern or that when people
hear the word radiation like what does
this mean it literally just means light
is what it means right but it's light in
different parts of the spectrum right
and so it turns out besides the visible
light that we can see here we are
immersed and almost the totality of the
electromagnetic spectrum there is
visible light there's infrared light
there is microwaves going around as
that's how our cell phone works you
can't it's way past our detection
capability but also higher energy ones
which have to do with ultraviolet light
how you get a sunburn
and even X-rays and things like this at
small levels are continually being like
from the concrete in this in the walls
of this hotel there's x-rays hitting our
body continuously I can bring out we can
go down to the lab at MIT can bring out
a detector and show you every single
room will have these by our body you
mean the 10 to the 28 atoms yeah the 10
to the 28 atoms and they're coming in
and they're interacting with those
things and those particularly the ones
where the light is at higher average
energy per per light particle those are
the ones that can possibly have an
effect on human health so we we it's
interesting humans and all animals of
evolved on Earth where we're immersed in
that all the time yeah there's natural
sources of radiation all the time yet we
have zero ability to detect it like zero
yeah and our ability cognitive ability
to filter it all out and not it would
not really overwhelm us actually if we
could see all of it but my main point is
it goes back to your thing about fire
and self-protection if if these ionize
if ionizing radiation was such a
critical aspect of the health of
organisms on Earth we would almost
certainly have evolved methods to detect
it and we have none
and uh yes the physical world that's all
around is incredible you're blowing my
mind uh Dr Dennis White